is the new mac studio with the m1 ultra
really worth buying instead of getting a
16 inch macbook pro fully loaded with
the 32 core m1 max and having the extra
portability well today we will find out
because we are going to be comparing a
ton of real world things such as cpu and
gpu performance photo editing video
editing coding music production 3d
rendering and more so we can find out
which is the smartest option is it
really that much faster to lock you into
a desktop let's go ahead and jump into
it now as far as specs you guys can see
right here both the prices and the
configurations of the systems we have
the four thousand dollar and one ultra
base model as well as the fully upgraded
in terms of performance with 128 gigs of
ram and the 64 core gpu our macbook is a
3500 model that does have the full cpu
and gpu performance in it starting off
with speedometer 2.0 for day-to-day
snappiness and regular tasks honestly
guys you will not notice the difference
both of these systems are insanely
snappy and that's also similar because
the geekbench single core performance is
almost identical the actual cores that
these chips use are the same now in
terms of multi-core performance the max
studios here have nearly double the
performance because they have literally
double the cores so you do have more
performance but we'll see how much that
actually makes a difference in real
world applications now as far as
cinebench when we're maxing out these
processors at full blast the scaling
once again is very good not double but
it is close so if you're rendering with
the cpu for example this test cinema 4d
well you do get a really good boost and
if you're working with stuff like this
all the time it is definitely worth it
if you could be at your desk now as far
as graphics testing out gfx benches
metal here we would expect to have a
doubling of performance from the 32 core
mmo max to the 64 core m1 ultra but in
reality we're only seeing a boost of 56
where it should be double now this is
very well optimized this is a gaming
benchmark that is really optimized for
metal and we're seeing these diminishing
returns now even the 310 fps in the m1
max also didn't scale well compared to
previous ships so as we see as we're
scaling in higher amounts we do get
those diminishing returns now 3d marks
wildlife is also a great benchmark and
here we're seeing actually better
scaling but it's still not double so do
not expect to get double the performance
and this is actually a really good
scenario we're gonna see some more
graphics results in just a bit now i
went ahead and i broke this down to the
amount of frame rates per core and the
32 core m1 max is 3.8 fps per core
compared to 3.3 so you guys see those
diminishing returns now jumping back
into some real world cpu tests as far as
xcode we see a difference of 23
now this is a bit disappointing because
xcode does use a lot of that unified
memory and also all the cpu cores get
maxed out now this is a broad benchmark
that was made for us by maxim erimenko
so if you have some things that maybe
lean more on the cores less on memory
you might see a bit of a boost uh but in
this case if i was somebody that worked
with xcode i would not buy the mac
studio because you get portability with
the macbook and the performance is so
good that it pretty much matches just a
couple seconds slower than the 28 core
mac pro that cost about 20 grand so you
might see that hey the mac studio is 23
faster but in reality it doesn't matter
both are insanely fast because of the
unified memory compared to previous
intel computers that you might own now
as far as music production with logic we
are using the new logic pro benchmark
you guys can go and check out all the
specifics there and we don't get double
scaling but it is kind of close it's
getting there this is cpu based so we're
getting a good difference in performance
but once again if you're somebody doing
this the amount of tracks and plug-ins
that the mac can handle with its unified
memory and having up to 64 gigs of ram
on the macbook it's just incredible and
having that portability for a lower
price and not having to buy a display
keyboard mouse all of that is so insane
it's going to handle the workload for
most people now for a very small select
few people out there that are used to
having you know 128 gigs 256 gigs of ram
with their intel system well you might
need the m1 ultra just to get more ram
to hold a lot more plug-ins but if
you're not somebody that absolutely
knows that you already need this well
then you don't the macbook is going to
be incredible for those of you guys
working with blender of course we have
the new metal based version of blender
and here we actually started out with
the ev engine which is great for
previous it's really quick and we are
not seeing really good scaling as far as
graphics which it uses at all now
switching over to cycles with gpu we're
seeing a boost i mean it is noticeable
here in party tug
but at the same time the scaling isn't
amazing
same thing goes for classrooms so i
would say if you are somebody that wants
to do a lot of 3d rendering and blender
exporting or other programs the ultra
will give you a better job but be
expect to wait roughly about a year to
get optimization we're actually talking
to multiple people that work with
software that say we need optimization
for these new ultra chips even though
apple said it shows up as one they are
not being fully utilized and they will
get a lot better in that case i would go
with an ultra now for you photo editors
out there
we're seeing some great improvements in
lightroom exporting is about 40 faster
in some tasks like previews it could be
up to 50 percent faster so the
performance is great now it's not
scaling double but i will say the
performance jump compared to intel to
the macbook was insane and if you're
somebody that needs the best performance
you're working with tons of files like
for example people do wedding
photography you have a lot of data or
you have huge uh for example panoramas
you will see a nice boost and it is
worth it if you want the most
performance now as far as day-to-day
editing adjusting layers for more basic
stuff i could not tell a difference
whatsoever so if you came more about
smoothness and brushes and stuff
i don't think it's worth it unless you
spend a lot of time sitting there
waiting for your system to render and
process now for photoshop the results
are even worse we did a huge panorama
with 16 50 megapixel raw images we
expect to see a good increase because we
have double the cpu performance at scale
as well but in fact the difference was
only about 18
faster photoshop is not well optimized
in general for higher performance it's
more single core based and with these
ultra chips it is not optimized at all
don't buy a mac studio if you spend a
lot of time in photoshop unless you need
128 gigs of ram and for video editing
this is where it gets tough because a
lot of programs including even davinci
resolve are not optimized for the m1
ultra yet we've waited two weeks to do
some of these video editing comparisons
apple hasn't even released the
prerelease final cut that they use for
all their performance stats on stage and
what they sent to their reviewers to
give great numbers to people they are
not releasing it we can't get our hands
on it now because of that if you're
working with regular h.264 files well
the performance is the same and not only
that but the gpu amount used working
with a 4k timeline which has multiple
effects color grades uh luts the gpus
only use 50
on the macbook pro
that means that you can stack multi-cam
you can stack crazy amounts of titles
and effects and you will not be affected
by it can handle it very well with this
macbook now if you go to h.265 you see
that the render times have not improved
at all
uh but it is much quicker so if you need
to speed up your system as far as
exports just go to h365 will give you a
nice improvement now as far as the
overhead here uh we're nearing 80 75
with the macbook meaning if you're
somebody has a lot of heavy effects and
titles you will benefit from a mac
studio
now as far as the heavier things this is
one area where some people would want to
buy a mac studio for example if you're
working with raw files if you're working
with prores we are seeing some
improvements but once again it's like 34
as far as regular 4k progress to
progress
that gain is there because we have extra
decoders that are being used uh but
unfortunately even with final cut the
gpus are not optimized well for these
ultra chips so the bottleneck here in
this test isn't actually the encoders
it is mostly just not enough graphics
performance the same thing for ak prores
raw
we're only seeing 22 percent faster
compared to the base four thousand
dollar one a little bit faster for the
64 core model
not a huge increase and it is
disappointing and then
as far as thermals and fans this thing
runs silent that's a huge benefit
compared to having a macbook on your
desk but the macbook as far as thermal
throttling even though in these crazy
tests like this 8k raw where it's maxing
out the cpu and the gpu
that is the only test where it will
throttle but even though it throttles
you don't lose that much more
performance and having double the cpu
cores double the gpu cores and four
times the memory only results in roughly
i don't know 40 faster exports in
handling so i would not worry about
thermal throttling and even fan noise in
the macbook unless you're really hitting
the cpu and gpu and that is quite rare
because most applications use either one
or the other now as far as value
proposition
if you want to get the best bang for the
buck if you care about that the macbook
pro is going to be your best bet 3 500
bucks it is incredibly fast
with the mac studio with the ultras you
have to spend more money you have to buy
a keyboard mouse and a display it is not
portable
you don't have the beautiful speakers
and everything built into here so you're
gonna spend a lot more money for not
that much more performance and we're
still gonna have to wait for more
optimizations so overall i think most of
you guys out there even if you're gonna
if you're willing to spend more to get
the ultras
your best bet is just to get a macbook
the value is incredible with what you
get and it's already gonna be so much
faster than your previous computer
that's what i would recommend to most of
you now for those of you guys that are
heavily
heavily
dependent on graphics if you do a ton of
8k raw in ak timelines and you need
really great playback uh or blender 3d
rendering it's all gpu based if you're
willing to wait for optimizations and
them taking a while
then maybe you can buy one of these but
expect to take some time to wait so
there you guys go let me know your
thoughts down below if you guys are
interested in seeing how this setup
compares with the base 2 000 one we
actually have a triple comparison that
falls in line with 24 car model on the
macbook as well you guys can check that
out right over there is so detailed and
click above to subscribe to help us
reach our goal of one million
subscribers we would definitely
appreciate it this has been max and i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]